we hear the phrase complicit that Jared  and Ivanka are complicit in what is  happening to the white house can you  just weigh in on how you feel about that  there have been articles there been  parodies what do you think about that  that accusation  if being complicit is wanting to is  wanting to be a force for good and to  make a positive impact  then I'm complicit I don't know that the  critics who may say that of me if they  found themselves in this very unique and  unprecedented situation that I am now in  would do any differently than I am doing  so I hope to make a positive impact I  don't know what it means to be complicit  but but you know I hope time will prove  that I have done a good job and much  more importantly that my father's  administration is the success that I  know it will be